you have an approval rating of the
United States Congress under 20% and you
have 90% re-election rates something is
very wrong with that high for recent
events in Kavanagh I'm here with bill
Mandel the executive producer of a new
documentary called gerrymandering and I
guess our first question should be is it
gerrymandering or is it gerrymandering
since it's named after our probably the
skinniest of the founding fathers
Elbridge Gerry well it's I I think we
probably ought to do of some good
service and call it gerrymandering
because he's certainly really best known
for that and in spite of the fact that
he was a signer of the Declaration of
Independence he was vice president under
Madison so he has a long history of
accomplishments but he's known for
gerrymandering or gerrymandering because
in 1812 as governor he made a point of
marginalizing his opposition to the
point that the opposition looked at the
districts that they were in and they
said it resembled a salamander and so
they put salamander together with
Governor Jerry and they got
gerrymandering you can talk about racial
gerrymandering where Jeremy might baby
White's
you can talk about partisan
gerrymandering where the lines are drawn
to favor a particular political party
the Democrats Republicans or you can
talk about incumbency gerrymandering
incumbency gerrymander the lines are
drawn to favor the incumbents sweetheart
deals as with sometimes baller
most people will never know whether
they've been gerrymandered out of a
district but they do know that our
country's infrastructure is crumbling
our economy is cratered and government
is broken and it turns out that the
arcane rules of redistricting impact all
this by determining who gets elected and
who gets represented now I think if you
ask the average person to look at a map
of their district and ask them if they
think it makes sense they will surely
say no because there's no rhyme or
reason they're not compact they're not
contiguous they don't give a sense of
any kind of community which is what
representation is all about the United
States is the only advanced democracy in
the world which allows politicians to
actually draw their district lines
so our redline if you will we say
there's no silver bullet and how you
create the Commission's to do this but
we just feel that the politician
shouldn't be directly involved in that
process it's completely self-serving and
we get the kind of districts we do
because of that that would bring us to
California with prop 11 and with the two
competing propositions that are coming
up in the current election prop 11
established a 14 person Commission to
oversee the redistricting of state
legislative districts correct the
purpose was to draw lines for the state
assembly the state Senate and the State
Board of Equalization all those lines
would now not be drawn in the
legislature by members of the
legislature they would be drawn by an
independent commission which was
selected to ensure a very non partisan
makeup this time around the proponents
of reform have tried to
extend exactly that proposition 11
Commission to congressional districts
one of the reasons why proposition 11
didn't face the kind of opposition that
we've had in the past is that it
excluded congressional district so
proposition 20 would in effect finish
the job but proponents of reform have
two jobs to do now in this election one
is to pass proposition 20 to extend it
to congressional districts but the other
is to win proposition 27 which would
rescind in effect proposition 11 and
roll back to a time when the legislators
are in control of everything
speaking of that we should probably talk
about the Texas example where the
Democrats famously lit out for the
border and stayed in a hotel and on the
border with Oklahoma three Democrats
from the Texas House of Representatives
bolted for the Oklahoma State Line
yesterday to prevent a vote which would
redraw voting districts that would favor
the Republican House Majority the delay
redistricting was a classic partisan
redistricting and you know it was a
power play the Republicans had control
and they decided they were going to
redraw the map to ensure that they got
more Republican congressional seats and
they did it they did it successfully
there was a lot of drama in it you had
you know it was really surreal when you
think of American democracy in one
breath and at the same time think about
bounty hunters chasing democratically
elected state legislators across state
lines who are holed up in a Holiday Inn
it's not exactly the first you know
conception of American democracy but but
I think those types of gerrymanders are
actually as as in the face as they are
there are less dangerous to the system
if you will than what I call a
bipartisan gerrymander because in a in a
partisan gerrymander there's always
another side to scream holy hell and and
people find out about and they
understand it's a power play in
California they actually pass
the 2001 gerrymander the day after 9/11
Zara Prada mr. president members this is
the Senate and congressional
redistricting for the decade bill I am
proud and happy to report that it has
bipartisan support and it was a
completely closed-door session between
Democrats and Republicans getting
together behind closed doors and the
public never heard about it and the
press for obvious reasons paid very
little attention to it because of the
timing of when they did that those are
the types of invisible gerrymanders that
I think really eat away at our system
because they disenfranchise people all
for incumbency protection that's the
goal it's not to the Democrats weren't
trying to get more seats the Republicans
weren't trying to get more seats
everybody just wanted to freeze the map
the way it was and you're seeing that in
both 2008 in the 2010 election which is
is really strikingly free of any kind of
competitive districts in California
there are one or two plays seats around
the state even at the state legislative
level that are actually competitive this
year yeah it's it's very very solenoid
you know you have I think in the last
decade you've had four congressional
elections in California and only one
time has a party changed hands during
you know four elections one change in
spite of the fact that we all know that
during that time period there were you
know huge levels of dissatisfaction with
the Congress I mean in terms of national
numbers you have an approval rating of
the United States Congress under 20% and
you have 90% re-election rates
something's very wrong with that the
bottom line is we want to have
competition you know whatever it is and
if that results in all left-wing
Democrats are all right wing Republicans
that's the way it ought to be they're
[ __ ] the districts should not be driven
and drawn in a way that is designed
solely to guarantee incumbency
protection it should be designed in a
way to enhance competition and the
competition
there's two forms of competition we're
talking about here one is of course
competitions between Democrats and
Republicans in any given congressional
seat or state assembly seat the other
form of competition that gerrymandering
hurts is intra-party competition it
minimizes the potential for intra-party
dissenters either on the Republican side
or the Democratic side and therefore
minimizes the free flow of ideas and so
the you know a stagnant a fixed
political system is a stagnant one you
don't get the kind of ideas that I think
are really essential to our democracy so
I it's it's even if the result of a
redrawn district lines in California by
an independent commission even if that
resulted in zero new competitive
districts I would argue that by removing
the power that party leaders have over
their members in the gerrymandering
process every ten years you were going
to enhance intra-party competition which
is a good thing for ideas and and and I
think American democracy